hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is garne an Irish and lives
between Berlin and London Zoe adjourn yo
is a chef and a writer right now she's
working on a memoir and runs a
successful pop-up restaurant called
Zoe's garner kitchen which sometimes
pops up in London and sometimes pops up
here in Berlin welcome to the show tell
us first of all for people who don't
know what's a pop-up restaurant um hi
thank you having me a pop-up restaurant
is a pop-up surg a term coined about six
or seven years ago I think the concept
kind of started then in England anyway
it just means the takeover us of a space
for any kind of temporary time so it
could be a day or a week or a month and
but the idea is that is temporary and
usually in a space more often than not
in a space that isn't designed for the
thing that's going to pop up there so I
do food but you know very often you can
get fashion boutiques or art galleries
or all sorts of popups really yeah so
what's the attraction for you if you say
it's often in a place that's not decide
no no I mean I'm thinking of food
straight away you need a kitchen you
know you need all sorts of facilities I
know and when I first started doing it
that used to really excite me like the
challenge of trying to cook in very odd
spaces that weren't really equipped and
it was part of the fun of creating a
restaurant in a completely different
environment it still is to a degree but
i prefer now to go to places that have
running water and you know um some kind
of kitchen facility just because it
doesn't make it a lot easier but it's
exciting to bring a whole new atmosphere
and environment to a space that's
usually quite often they're not used for
anything in particularly the dead space
is that's the beauty of popups they take
over direct spaces and turn them into
something creative and interesting and
bring people to them whether it was it
actually do you know was it invented
inning in Britain I've got no idea to be
honest I doubt it I mean
it's not that it's been huge in London
anyway for at least six or seven years
possibly yeah and it's starting to
become quite a big thing in Berlin as
well actually yeah you said it you know
it needs running water the sort of me
have you actually done one without
running water then yeah I mean it to be
honest you could transfer that side of
street food as well so very often and
street food environments you don't have
a kitchen and you don't have running
water so you are installing temporary
cooking facilities and using like
gallons using water with a tap on it and
stuff like that so it's a lot of
improvised A's improvisation goes on in
that environment so it's not as
difficult as perhaps it sounds but you
eat oh I've got to a stage where I'd
rather have it a little bit easier than
not and that's your side of it now how
about the people who want to go and eat
there if you like in that how do they
get to know about it then cuz it sounds
quite secretive and well I'm okay well
you know I mean obviously this way is it
social media social media mostly I've
got quite a big mailing list now both
London and Berlin so I mean it's a lot
of people just spread the word that just
word of mouth people tell other people
and that's kind of how am I my purse my
business is grown organically through
that kind of and people telling other
people about it but then yell you social
media a lot and how do you find premises
again that's become a lot easier and the
last year or so because now you have
networks specifically designed to
connect landlords with you know small
businesses or pop-up businesses and to
negotiate fair rents and you know
temporary use of space and stuff and be
the first everyone I didn't Billy and I
did it in a friend's apartment and then
just in bars and stuff I just told
people i'm doing this to either come
people came and but now yet people
recommend spaces or there are networks
designed to tell ya well now you're in a
position you you're here in Berlin and
people are waiting you know sort of at
the door rydia you're booked out I know
and I I want to ask you sent us some
pictures that's all our guests do
yeah I last few way as she wasn't that
what I was gonna show first of all of
you oh this this now if this isn't pop
up exactly hang on you've gotta there's
no picture up our dear technology oh yes
there's a picture hopefully yeah that's
a picture that's now this is in Russia
yes so this was very exciting actually I
was invited and as an artist rather than
the chef to be part of a group
exhibition for a festival called
decisive action so it's the NCCA ral the
Center for Contemporary Art all right
they were having a group show some and i
did a food performance which was a
supper club in a public park basically
because my supper club events the pop-up
restaurant they've they're very more
their experiential if you like because I
host it and I'm involved with everything
that's going on and so we did this yeah
in a public space certainly involved in
this picture yeah um this is though I've
heard the basis the this drink ya allah
knows this is a code of this is a snaps
that's devilish astir it is quite
evident it's called Alamo bitters so
it's widely drunken Ghana as kind of a
herbal remedy basically but it's very
strong alcohol content and when I found
out about it I was like amazing and I
also found out that it's used by men as
an aphrodisiac so then that doubled my
interest immediately so yeah I always
end all of the supper clubs giving
everybody a shot of bitters and there's
like a little speech that goes with it
and everybody loves it ok none people
everyone don't know taste necessarily
but they has to be yeah we have to Nick
it real okay Leah um what initially
brought you to Germany its burned-in
yeah yeah so I was doing him as you
mentioned I'm a writer as well so I was
studying part-time that MA and creative
and life writing at Goldsmiths at the
time and miss about three years ago and
we had a summer break and some
colleagues some co-writers on the course
and I decided to have a little trip
around Europe kind of like a writing
trip i guess and then so we went through
various countries and we always were
planning to
in berlin and we did and I just fell in
love with birding and i ended up staying
i supposed to be here two weeks and i
end up staying for three months and at
the end of the three months i was
running out of money quite frankly so i
did they're gone a kitchen just like
boost my all right i get money and then
yeah then i guess they love affair with
billion started then and i was after
that first supper club and somebody did
a review in tip berlin and i got that's
a local yeah magazine now yes like a
time out london but thinking the rest of
the world yes it it's a city guys it's a
city right yeah and then got a right up
in their wishes yeah that's always
creates got a huge response and so i had
so many bookings people trying to book
for the next one which took me aback
actually but it meant i had a reason to
come back very quickly so I'm sorry
that's what's been happening ok let's
see Zoe in action so to speak out her
pop-up restaurant here in Berlin our
lucky reporter you hannahs also got to
taste the goods a cultural center in
Berlin's hypno cool neighborhood people
enjoy the evening sun while waiting for
a gastronomic treat inside in the
kitchen Zoe a John yo is making final
preparations for tonight's event this
summer she moved her pop-up kitchen to
Berlin together with her team Zoe offers
a special dinner with homemade
delicacies from Ghana
the Zoey does not like limiting herself
to managing the evening she takes part
in every single step of the operation
and her cooking Zoey tries to keep the
dishes as traditional as possible a stew
with both chicken and fish in it and
some spicy chilies on top is a challenge
for European tastes but Zoe wants the
evening to be a special culinary
experience tonight she's expecting
around 40 guests the dishes are also
served by the chef herself
Zoey gives a short briefing about what
the dishes are and of course how to eat
them
soon the customers get used to eating
with their hands and although some are
struggling with the hot spices and
unfamiliar flavors everyone seems to be
enjoying their gastronomic adventure
it's really nice I mean the spiciness we
don't need this far as I thought it
would pay though I think and the chef
herself seems to be more than happy with
the outcome of the evening and the chef
herself designs t-shirts to actually did
you design this I bet actually my friend
he does all my graphic design for me who
created my logo yes sir he actually came
up with the tie-dye t-shirt okay is this
a tie-dye t-shirt I used to wear
t-shirts like this mm-hmm for two years
ago but Zoe is very kindly given us two
t-shirts some recipe cards to give away
and some legendary she told us this is
dangerous i believe is it it can be I've
given you a mild one it's still hot but
it's not going to blow your palate off
but I'm still pretty spicy it's got a
kick on a scale from one to ten I'm
gonna put that as a 6 ok yeah ok ok but
I mean actually I I don't know I mean I
my wife loves hot sauces and our African
sources the hottest they they just stay
there I mean I think so you can get them
the ingredients for example in the sheet
Oh is there very simple it's lots of
ground crayfish and ground porns is
about thirty percent chilly in that one
and then it's like if that the hot one
is like 50 potentially anyway we're
giving these away in that I don't quite
know how we're going to send this
through the post but we will we will do
it if you're interested in going into
the drawer there's where only one winner
I'm afraid write to us at insight at DW
de that address will appear at the end
of the program as well um thank you for
those welcome now you've done it in
London you've done it in Berlin what's
the difference skala some differences
it's good question and I think the
difference in Berlin is that there's a
lot of competition for food I mean
there's a lot of competition for food in
London and without being disparaging two
billion pallets I think um that people
are more readily able to spend money on
going out eating in London I think like
there's a real strong food culture of
wanting to experience new and different
cuisines I think people in Berlin
there's definitely community who are
interested in then aventuras with food
but I think a lot of people because you
can get so much good cheap food in
Berlin people um you know perhaps on
some people aren't quite as adventurous
and then some people aren't quite as
willing to spend that a little bit extra
to try something do you mean bit
different yeah and I wonder i mean i
don't know but i would suspect you have
to charge less money here in Berlin I do
yeah and yet you say that they're still
not well it's interesting I have to
charge less but my costs are actually
higher obviously because I have to come
over and then the ingredients are more
expensive in Berlin yeah I wanted to ask
about that because I'm in London I mean
London is so multicultural obviously I
didn't even think to ask you where you
get your ingredients there but I mean is
it could you can you get everything do
you have to come up with ok nice nice
joke about it but yeah this is the first
one I ever did in billion I had real
trouble actually try and track down a
fro m shops where I could buy the
ingredients and I went on my body
stupidly on my bike as well I went all
over Berlin at certain guides such a
long time to gather up everything and
but since then I'm is actually very
strong I've learners are quite a big gun
and community in bed in and this seems
to be quite condensed in nikon if i'm
not wrong
might be wrong but it's a lot there's a
lot of them yeah there's quite a lot of
African grocery shops there most of
which I can I in Italy and m's I've
built up relationships with the ladies
that run those places and um yeah so
super easy now but it's more expensive
here these tend to charge more I don't I
guess because this is a supply and
demand thing isn't it I guess people
aren't it's not like really road i live
in Hackney so you know it's cheaper
chips talking about garne inand thinks I
mean your London are really you know if
I may say so um but I believe you went
to Ghana yes sort of find out more about
the cuisine really I mean did you yeah
yeah yeah that's true and a couple years
ago I mean I actually spent a couple of
years and Ghana as a child but hadn't
been back for a very long time and as
this guy on a kitchen was kind of
developing momentum and getting bigger
and I was like I'm goodness we have to
diversify my menu I'm gonna have to do
all these different things so on a joint
research trip for my my memoir and for a
recipe and collecting mission I guess I
went back a couple of years ago and then
yeah it was really good fun yeah I mean
I suppose this that had nothing to do
with your memoir or your recipes but
that look there's just a great pictures
that was like an archaeological dig no
no that was me just having some I went
on a bit of an adventure obviously doing
a bit traveling around go on and that's
in the volta region Willie Falls and
funniest thing actually this picture I I
walked out under the waterfall and when
I came back all of these kids were they
all climbed on top of me like those are
nodes of kids and that was at the end of
them get back climb down okay how much
of a picture now show some more pictures
cuz you go up your mouth um first of all
this I just love this picture for your
mum your mum looks so cool hey yeah yeah
yeah that's and we were living in
deptford then so I'm a chubby little
toddler my mom's looking pretty pretty
fly i have to say that yeah and there's
one of but what way that's not it one of
both your parents and at this point i
should ask you was it your father who
sort of in influence
at all with the cooking on now well yeah
I mean in a way this has been
misrepresented a few times actually but
I mean obviously my my dad's gone a and
so that's where my influence comes from
my mom's Irish em and yeah it was a case
of watching him bringing home some very
strange ingredients wondering what that
was and more often than not he would
cook for himself I think he didn't
realize that we had an interest and but
yes a couple of times I used to kind of
bug him to teach me on what's that
you're making and what's going on there
if he wasn't around I believe when you
were slow so it was around that much so
I mean definitely that's the intrigue
was with the food came from and the
palate forex yeah he cooked hot yeah but
yeah but so yeah it's been an
interesting journey thing because doing
the garlic kitchen like through food has
been sort of a way into that side of my
culture actually yeah that's been
interesting journey and but you didn't
start in food you did a law degree or
you started one did you finish it no
finish thanks oh really yeah we have a
lawyer in this Judy I better be careful
why oh yeah I mean I've never really
settled into anything quite as one of us
as I've settled into this it's funny one
but I've done lots of different things
yeah I'd studied Lord been a music
promoter and manager did some journalism
work for tech companies creative
production stuff I've done all kinds of
jobs really I even had a job Tanning's
plants on the side of highways yeah but
but I mean if perhaps a more serious a
thing and I mean we've all I think
another I mean certainly I've done many
things are minor but writing is a sort
of continuing thing is is that she is
writing number one or yeah I cooking
number one I mean I'm cooking baby how
you made your living more at the moment
but yeah I mean I think that probably
it's a combination of the two eventually
but I mean writing was always something
I was scared to go off there because you
know when you really want to do
something you're scared of not being
able to do it i think that's thing and
whereas i fell into cooking
it's quite organic and strange journey
to where I am now at cooking but writing
is still like my you know if I don't
finish this book I will be very unhappy
okay what is there that means can you
tell us a bit about the book it uses its
entry it's a memoir it's a memoir um so
the idea is that it's created its
creative nonfiction so it's storytelling
it's like episodes of my life that have
built up to the point of where i am now
so i guess it's been on hold a little
bit because so much has happened in the
last two years or the year and a half
i'm probably going to incorporate food
with it in some way so it's probably
going to become more of a i'm not sure
maybe a cookbook with a lot of like
shorts and so episodic memoir but is it
I mean is it also going back to your
roots and oh yeah really and it's a lot
there's a lot of good island in it it's
got a bit of Ireland it's got a lot of
my dad a lot of Ghana and a lot of all
of those dynamics yeah what about though
a straight cookbook yeah what about it
bye to be honest I'm so there's just too
many but that is because they know
itself haha I'd love to do one you know
and it's definitely something i want to
just having the time isn't it yeah but I
should think people are interested
because the i mean i i've reserved done
research on you it's obviously a lot of
people very interested in zona Zoe's go
on a kitchen you know is it you you
haven't got enough time I know because
we've been trying to get in touch with
you know I mean there's certainly an
interest and I do do cookery lessons and
stuff from people you have time for that
I know because even and but now there's
an appetite thing there is generally an
appetite for people African cuisine is
on the rise generally I think it has
been for the last few years and I think
we're gonna see in the next year or so
like an explosion and different kind of
African scenes on street food scene and
the pop-up scene and definitely probably
there will be you'll see a lot more
African cooks one TV and cookbooks I
think I think that is our cue
you actually we because Street food much
like you'll find in Asia or Africa has
arrived here in Germany and rather like
those pop-up restaurant it's proving to
be very very popular this is the knowing
market hall in Berlin's kreuzberg
district there's a street food market
here every Thursday featuring cuisine
from around the world
you're encouraged to eat standing up and
it's fine to eat with your fingers DD is
mentally calf manatee mooted can do you
want to try a lot of different foods and
meet a lot of different people it's the
people who created these dishes well
that's in tomorrow we also want to offer
food that's affordable you can walk
around try different kinds of food and
learn about different cultures the item
in court one can Lankan for example
kimchi quesadillas and Korean beef tacos
prepared by lauren lee she's Korean
American and after living in Los Angeles
has brought her unique blend of Korean
and Mexican cuisine to Berlin what's
special about the street food market
here is that we're mostly small
producers here that all love the things
were making and we really take the time
and the effort to really make a nice
product food trucks are increasingly
turning up in big cities in Germany
American Billy Davis used to operate a
taco truck in his home state of Texas
now he's doing it in Berlin but the
authorities still haven't given him a
license for sales on public streets
there hasn't been any history of that
and yeah so it seems very foreign and
new and may be difficult for them to to
to accept the high sahaba turns up every
week at the street food market in
Berlin's Crites back district it
features freshly prepared cheese
specialties from Germany's algo region
lots of people come to the market to try
something new others are just looking
for a little piece of home never
before
these are pierogi from Poland it was my
mom's favorite dish she made them all
the time from a recipe our family had
used for generations I just wanted to
try one
isn't shitty beef pie chili beef pies
from New Zealand never seen it before
but it tastes great some experts say
that street food in Germany may soon
offer some serious competition to sit
down restaurants street food country two
hours that could certainly happen street
food restaurants provide a more diverse
selection of food items a wide selection
of cuisines from a number of different
countries and they do it at a price that
restaurants just can't match I'm passage
garbage has two more visitors on each
slice okay street food is also a way for
young chefs like Lauren lead to make a
statement you can serve first break
cuisine on a paper plate just like they
do now here in Berlin
my guest is a Johnny Oh runs a pop-up
restaurant either here everywhere and
you do street food did he should be and
you've been there I've been there it's
great actually know the lady kavita
who's one of the people who founded and
started that it's amazing and I've seen
it gathers such momentum in the past two
years it's like crazy and what do you do
it yeah I think I mean then we were in
conversation a little bit a long time
ago about me having a stall there and I
would love to but just my schedule at
the time was a bit hectic but this will
be as that report says the same as
London Street food is influencing
restaurant menus and really you know
taking over the food scene and I think
it's great that that was happening in
Berlin yeah I mean funny enough people
this is an international broadcast of
people watching Asia and Africa thing
what we'd be doing this all our lives
weren't they yeah they will you know
they know and understand why it's taken
so long yeah and but it really is
revolutionising how people eat and the
access to good quality and international
foods that very reasonable prices so
it's there can't be anything wrong with
that a new london is a big center of
this and you now comfortable in east
berlin you on the on on the continent as
the brits would say their path of it
actually but would you say Berlin's the
next the second place for that sort of a
tough I mean having seen that report
your experience is yeah I mean I can
only speak from my experience but I
think so what I've seen is like a huge
growth in that kind of activity and as I
said and more and more pop-ups are
happening in Berlin more important or
like food entrepreneurs and the focus
because i think in England there's been
a concentration on food like there's
been lots of TV food programs probably
too many in the last 10 years and no
food culture is just crazy in England in
a good way and I think that kind of is
Berlin's adopting a similar similar
outlook on food and taking it seriously
and wanting to try new things
you do festivals as well I believe
what's that isn't that must be quite
parrot well hair-raising I would have
thought I mean do cook on a grand scale
then for thousands yeah it's hard work
festivals but it's a lot of fun yes I
recently did them I was invited to be
part of something called the feast
collective which was a speciality food
tent at Camp Bestival and best of all
and it was really good fun and you know
you put in with some of some great names
we've been doing excellent street food
for years you're like um yeah it's a
demanding environment it's challenge but
you know it's super amazing when you get
the feedback people loving it and coming
back day after day because I think
that's something that's gonna come over
here a lot more too because more and
more there are vast amount of festivals
in Great Britain and more and more of
the man just pop festivals they're doing
all sorts of stuff lots of food me I
don't feel festival is it yeah yeah they
come out as well now I think people want
more than them hot dogs and burgers and
out festival was because of that is
moving from the high street feels a
little bit yeah the palette the European
power oh yeah what about German cuisine
I've got to ask you you know I mean what
do you think of it tell us tell us and
it's a that's a good question i don't
know that i've had this is gonna sound
ridiculous actually but i haven't had an
amazing amount of german food apart from
when I've been in regional areas where
that's like the cuisine and yeah there's
a lot of pickled stuff isn't there and
then I love strudel but my favorite
thing that I've experiences my was
living with one of my friends Tosh who's
from Bavaria originally he introduced me
to the Bavarian breakfast and I'm you
know white sausage pretzel and some
really delicious honey mustard and it's
like that's the best German food that i
have i've had yeah now that we have to
explain this is it we've actually shown
a piece on my program but people don't
watch it all the time i'm sure this is a
white sausage which you think yeah I
remember myself the fur
time I ate it I I sort of had to grip
myself thinking somebody's giving me
this and I've got to eat this and it's
delicious he's absolutely delicious but
I wasn't afraid of white sausage because
my mum's Irish and so you have white
their black pudding and white pudding
and yeah it's all delicious yeah but M
yes an interesting and and of course
this is as you say breakfast yes sausage
a pretzel and mustard this isn't hot
mustard this is a sweet master suite
must it is absolutely delicious but you
know in Ghana for breakfast they have
cheeto and YJ and yeah you know so yeah
um what don't you like about the German
cuisine I think I'm not a massive fan of
sauerkraut but pickled cabbage which
seems to be mr. famous thing isn't it
every sauerkraut I'm sure this my
particular palette is not inclined
towards that that's it okay okay okay
this was its possession you said this
about the vivere breakfast did our
question and I want to ask you about
things your answer because you put I
thought this was an interesting answer
from you as well you put for the coolest
living German remember what you poor
thing up the angler Merkel yeah I mean
I'm sure she'd be really flattered a
young person young cool person well
thinking she's the coolest living
Germantown tell me why I think well
aren't you know I don't really know what
Germans think of Angela Merkel to be
honest but you know she's been rocking
it for Germany hasn't shaved the past
was it ten years yeah she's a woman
she's a leader States woman she's yeah
she's done wonderful things for German
economy she seems to be pretty cool and
she attended the she at the world cup
final thing she was so in a team no no
she wouldn't missed that option I know
she was there remember yeah I have them
whether or not she's the coolest living
German I don't know but I've got a lot
of respect for ever how do you think
actually the Brits I mean I left Britain
25 years ago to live here and I'm
wondered what you think
25 years ago I'm thinking footballs
reminded me of this the attitude towards
the Germans was pretty appalled if I may
say so my fellow countrymen I think
that's changed a lot hasn't it I mean
it's interesting you for instance I mean
you live you live here as well but you
you know saying how good angle Merkel is
what do you think the general attitude
towards Germans and the Germany is that
from there gosh and i know i think that
britain and the whole has become less
Sinha phobic then probably those times
you're talking about and it kind of
adopted being European as reality and
the welcome reality rather than there's
more Pro you Europeans and there are
Nick you know negatives I think and then
I think there's still some stereotypes
probably about beach towels and things
like that but I don't know it's not
fooling the beach house oh yeah I think
everybody in the world I don't have to
explain that one and yeah yeah generally
I mean you know lots of people i know
love Berlin for example and lots of
people come here all the time you also
put down as ingenious German invention
abs and or Auto screen the abs r is the
anti-lock braking system so you bit of a
fan of German cars and driving on the
Autobahn or what's that well it's more
than what i like about those kind of
inventions and i think this is a
particularly german thing actually is
that is creative design like to the inth
degree it's like really thinking about a
solution to like a problem that most
people would never have imagined as an
issue agent it mean that before the ABS
is that well you know so what so what
and then it's invented in it yeah and we
can't do without it yeah and I know the
windows yeah so I did want to say I have
an admiration for the from every place
I've ever stayed in Berlin has these
double open windows so you can open them
two ways open yeah you know that way
sort of that way and then you change a
thing in the oven I think it's really
clever but
don't know if it's a German invention
that's anything I think it must be a lot
of people have talked about this and
foreigners are always terribly impressed
by this being so simple it's not do you
remember what you put down for your
favorite german word i want you to say
it you see come on it's a nice long with
slate hey it's matchbox in German German
German it's so not like slicing nice
nice okay I'll say it strike hold
shuttle that's the one yes so many CH is
in that yeah and you put it about the
worst thing about living in Germany so
many tricky words to get your tongue
around so we'll forgive you about that
one the wisest German you put down as
Einstein you put a quote here that I'll
quote to you that I fear that Einstein
said I fear the day that technology will
surpass our human interaction which was
prophetic it was very prophetic but
without social media your your existence
wouldn't exist with it I mean you know
that's not well possibly no possible ah
yeah but you know yeah there's a bit of
a conflict burst um you know I didn't
have social media when I started and
people use the old-fashioned word of
mouth it's heading people okay fair
enough finally it is the questioner I
want to read should you put down as
memorable German music krautrock yeah
yeah that it because you couldn't have
been around when krautrock was around
tell us about krautrock why about what
well and so I was turned on to Carol by
a friend of my Laura who was she's been
a researcher for BBC programming and
worked on lots documentaries and she
there was an excellent documentary back
route work krautrock so and watched it
and I was and I didn't realize actually
how much music I was familiar with that
was part of that scene like it was a
defined kind of movement and and yeah
and the but you know i think crowd what
kind of defines German what's good about
German music they
you think like well that's fine now
let's find out a bit more krautrock was
a style typifying by long instrumental
solos and the tendency to take
experimental wrist but krautrock was
also very much a way of life so that's
krautrock for you do you have do you
have albums now of krautrock you a
digitally digitally oh gosh I should be
asking what's an album of course I beg
your car please actually have a fairly
decent record collection but yeah yeah I
should mention my guest is Zoe adanya
whose likes krautrock but runs pop-up
restaurants lives between Berlin and
London and writing um what's next
writing why I mean you've got to finish
this book well how you gonna do that
yeah it's good question and yeah so I
think as I said I'm going to change
focus a little bit next year and I'm
hoping to set up a restaurant in London
so most of that the first part of next
year will be focused on getting that and
nailed down I hope and then so no more
pop-ups I know I mean I'll always do the
the supper clubs and tore them I mean
I'm talking to people in Paris in New
York about taking them there as well i
mean that's just it's really fun it's
like i love doing the pop-ups you know
and they will always exist but like
having a fixed place is in a little chop
bar it's a natural progression how do
you work that out i mean you're talking
to people in Paris and New York you say
I mean if you're gonna go to New York um
and just do a couple of nights or no
surely not that is that sort of
financially viable and well it kind of
it doesn't matter in a way for that kind
of I mean you've got to exist that I
mean you gotta we're living him yeah we
know knows I'm not imagining you're
greedy and stuff like that no but mean
when I first came to Berlin I wasn't
making it wasn't a profitable exercise
either but the pro
father gave me has led on to other
things that make it yeah it makes it
work so I kind of just love to do
something in New York to get some
profile in New York and just to have a
trip to New York to be honest and so be
fun and hopefully make a little bit of
money but probably not enough to cover
the flights but sometimes you just do
stuff because you want to thank you yeah
yeah sure um and what about um cuisine
we obviously you are known for ghanian
cuisine you spend a lot of time cooking
I imagine look at reading inventing you
know tasty have you been you're gonna
spread your wings Cullen Andrew it
what's the word I marry in in a culinary
way and it's all away from Ghana and at
all no I mean you know I'm not a trained
chef I'm like a home cook whose happen
to do quite well at cooking food that I
love and I've grown up with and I've got
no ambitious to be like some kind of
master chef you know I cooked ghanian
food well and I love cooking it I don't
you know I cook other food obviously at
home but I don't want to make her not
vying for a place in any other no I
didn't mean that though I mean I just
thought you might be intrigued to sort
of Oh try other staff and you you 4ever
reinventing our name food as well and
take it further perhaps I mean there's
always room for me I love food you know
and I love eat trying new food from
different places and and yes sometimes
it's good when you cook too happy
informed by different flavors and
different styles of food definitely that
helps and some of what i do is
reinventing gonna ingredients and you
know no or reinventing the dishes using
solid ingredients rather um so yeah and
everything every time you try new food
you can't help but be infinite somehow
okay well you know thanks very much for
being with us today do look out for
zoe's garner kitchen it seems to be
going a New York Paris
could be Australia wherever I mean is
the world's your oyster as they say now
well the world is everybody's oyster
yeah okay all right don't desert Berlin
I'm telling you and if you want to enter
our competition for this fabulous
t-shirt there's two actually and some
hot sauce and some recipes don't forget
to write to incite at DWD I think this
is rather fetching on me actually don't
you yeah that's it I could get good bye
see you next time bye bye
you